digamos que comenzamos con una población
de 1000 conejos y sabemos que esta
población no crece a 10% cada mes lo que
quiero hacer es explorar cómo crecerá
esta población
si es que crece 10% por mes vamos a
dibujar una tabla y en la columna de la
izquierda pondremos el número de meses
que han pasado y en la columna de la
derecha pondremos la población con la
información que tenemos sabemos que a
los 0 meses comenzamos con 1000 conejos
ahora pensemos lo que va a ocurrir
después de un mes bueno la población va
a crecer un 10% así que podemos tomar
nuestra población al inicio del mes y el
crecimiento del 10% que es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 1.1 tenemos a la
población original y el crecimiento del
10% 1 más 10 por ciento es 1.1 hacemos
esta multiplicación mentalmente lo que
nos da 1100 pero vamos a escribirlo como
1000 por 1.1
ahora veamos qué sucede en el segundo
mes pues vamos a tener la población que
teníamos al principio del mes
multiplicada por 1.1 de nuevo así que es
la población que teníamos al inicio del
mes que es esta pero la multiplicamos de
nuevo por 1.1 o podemos decir que la
multiplicamos por 1.1 al cuadrado así
que pueden ver que aquí emerge un patrón
para el siguiente mes la población será
1000 por 1.1 al cubo estamos
multiplicando de nuevo por 1.1 así que
si quieren conocer a la población en el
enésimo mes será 1000 por 1.1 a la n o
multiplicado por 1.1 n veces podemos
definir una expresión podemos decir que
la población que es p la población como
función de n será igual a nuestra
población inicial multiplicado por 1.1
elevado a la enésima potencia ustedes me
pueden decir muy bien esto tiene sentido
ya que parece
que no tendremos cantidades locas pero
digamos que queremos conocer lo que
ocurrirá en diez años diez años serán
120 meses por lo que será 1000 por 1.1
elevado a 120 vamos a usar la
calculadora para encontrar este número
ya que no puedo hacer mentalmente este
cálculo 1.1 elevado a 120 es igual a
esto multiplicado por nuestra población
original o sea x mil 123 por lo que será
igual aproximadamente a 93 millones de
conejos vamos a escribirlo así pues
comenzamos con 1000 y ahora tendremos
aproximadamente 93 millones de conejos
crecieron con un factor de 93.000
durante 10 años es decir dentro de otros
10 años tendremos esto multiplicado por
93.000 como nuestro crecimiento de la
población con esto nos damos cuenta de
que a un crecimiento del 10 por ciento
mensual es muy rápido y aunque nos
parezca muy raro
no es algo descabellado para una
población de conejos que no está
limitada por espacio comida o
depredadores y si ustedes quisieran
graficar esta población de conejos con
respecto al tiempo luciría más o menos
así este es el eje del tiempo digamos en
meses y este es el eje en donde
tendremos nuestra población este tipo de
función o ecuación para esta población
es una función exponencial así que
nuestra población como función del
tiempo va a verse así como una jota y si
dejamos que estos conejos se reproduzcan
lo suficiente podrían saturar al planeta
si es que tuvieran el espacio y el
alimento suficiente para hacerlo pero no
tengo que sigo diciendo las condiciones
de suficiente espacio y suficiente
alimento pero en la realidad no existe
el espacio infinito o el alimento
infinito y tampoco es que no existan
depredadores o que no haya competencia
por los recursos por lo que existe una
capacidad de carga máxima en cierta
parte del ambiente para cierto tipo de
especies
lo que es más probable que pase bueno
esto que escribimos aquí es crecimiento
exponencial y por qué se llama
crecimiento exponencial bueno no tengo
que estamos creciendo por la entrada que
es el tiempo y que está en nuestro
exponente y es por eso que lo llamamos
crecimiento exponencial pero obviamente
no podemos tener un número infinito de
conejos no puede aumentar eternamente
siempre va a existir una capacidad de
carga máxima natural que el ambiente
puede soportar así pues el crecimiento
real que veremos cuando la población
está muy por debajo de la capacidad de
carga se modela razonablemente bien con
el crecimiento exponencial pero conforme
se acerca más y más a la capacidad de
carga va a comportarse como una asín
total hacia esta se va a seguir
acercando pero nunca la va a alcanzar
este es sólo un modelo quizá haya otras
situaciones en donde pueda superar
momentáneamente dicha capacidad de carga
luego volver a bajar y honduras y a su
alrededor
hay muchas formas de pensar en esto pero
la idea general es que no podemos
esperar que algo crezca sin
restricciones para siempre esta curva
verde que es con frecuencia usada para
modelar una población en especial cuando
esta población comienza a acercarse a la
capacidad de carga del ambiente esta
curva verde con forma de s
se le llama crecimiento logístico y
existe una función que la describe pero
no necesitan conocerla para esta
biología introductoria si tienen
curiosidad por conocer más sobre esto en
khan academy tenemos vídeos sobre
crecimiento logístico y también sobre
crecimiento exponencial donde vemos esto
con más detalle pero la idea general es
que cuando las poblaciones no están
limitadas por su medio ambiente por el
espacio por los recursos o por el
alimento van a tender a crecer
exponencialmente sin embargo el
crecimiento exponencial ya no es un buen
modelo cuando la población comienza a
saturar su medio ambiente y comienzan a
acercarse a este máximo y la función
logística o crecimiento logístico
un mejor modelo de lo que va a ocurrir
en realidad